good morning again everyone I'm Stacy
Arneson I'm chief of the disaster
information management research center
here at the National Library of Medicine
and I will be introducing our speakers
today thank you so much for joining the
humanitarian evidence week webinar on
improving the about the availability of
reliable health information we have two
speakers today dr. Neal Pakenham Walsh
and Robin Taylor and before I introduce
them I will take just a few moments to
describe the National Library of
Medicine and its disaster information
management Research Center or dim Rex I
think most of you probably know the
National Library of Medicine or NLM it
is the world's largest biomedical
library and part of the United States
National Institutes of Health
NLM has provided health information for
over 180 years most of you are probably
familiar with PubMed or MEDLINE which is
the index of the biomedical journal
literature and perhaps PubMed Central
the full-text archive with over 4
million full-text articles available for
free and others might be familiar with
our resource for the general public
known as MEDLINE plus which you may not
be familiar or aware of the wealth of
other databases and resources from NLM
and specifically I'm talking about those
in disaster medicine and public health
emergencies for nearly 10 years and elem
has had a disaster information a
disaster information management Research
Center also known as damn rec that it
has developed and provided resources for
that disaster medicine and public health
emergency community we change or go to
the next slide on yes thank you as you
see here our vision ties in with the
humanitarian evidence week webinar today
to connect the disaster medicine and
public health emergency community to
evidence-based quality disaster health
information and innovative informatics
tools to foster a culture of community
resiliency and to enhance health
security
our activities are broad and range from
the traditional access to literature
such as disaster lit which we'll hear
more about today and PubMed which I
already mentioned as along with subject
or information guides to also training
librarians and actually anyone
interested in health information related
to disasters through our disaster
information specialist certificate
program which has a number of courses
including a brand-new one that we'll
talk about later on packing your digital
Go Bag as well as developing tools and
apps several for C burn incidents also
known as chemical biological
radiological or nuclear incidents well
now let's focus on the evidence-based
literature and resources first we are
going to hear from Robin Taylor who
works in dim rec she's been here for
about a year and a half she is a
librarian that recently earned her MLIS
last December previously she's worked at
the Library of Congress and with various
Library and Information organizations
during for seven years living in Africa
she will be followed by dr. Neil
Pakenham Walsh who is the coordinator of
HIPAA the healthcare information for all
campaign he is also coordinator of the
global healthcare information network he
is chair of D groups foundation a
partnership promoting a dialogue for
international health and development and
he started his career as a hospital
doctor in the UK and also has clinical
experience in isolated as a isolated
healthcare worker in rural Ecuador and
Peru for the past 20 years he has been
committed to the global challenge of
improving the availability and use of
relevant reliable health care
information for health workers and
citizens in low and middle income
countries and he is based in Oxford near
Oxford so I will turn it over to Robin
now Thank You Stacy she gave great
overview of our activities and dimmer
and as she mentioned today for today's
webinar I'm going to focus on our
disaster list database so first I'm
going to give it over view of the
disaster list the scope of our documents
our intended audience and the resources
within
starting with the audience we have two
broad audiences to two primary audiences
for disaster lit and for all our
disaster health information one is the
disaster workforce which includes
professionals such as emergency
responders and healthcare professionals
that respond to disasters the second
audience is librarians not just medical
and health science librarians but even
public librarians who are interested in
preparing their own libraries and also
helping their communities prepare for
disasters our audience are stated
audience is not general public though of
course they are always welcome to use
our resources but the language in the
types of documents we we include are
going to be more appropriate for a
professional audience that is familiar
with the disaster vocabulary and
principles of response and recovery
so why librarians and libraries well
there's a few reasons on the slide that
you can read in librarians are
information specialists information is
key in a disaster a librarians are also
service-oriented and based in their
communities and they're familiar with
many people in their communities and the
libraries themselves are the physical
infrastructure is an information hub
with computers internet access sometimes
in the middle of a disaster it may be
the only place with electricity and the
fourth bullet there is a link I will
show you we have a bibliography to show
you what kinds of different ways that
libraries have been responding to
disasters so you can see already and
2017 we have some articles that about
librarians responding to the protest and
violence in charlottesville responding
to the opioid disaster and responding to
the Hurricanes from this remarkable
hurricane season and it's official as
well in the most recent version of the
Stafford act FEMA has named libraries as
an essential community service which
makes them eligible for federal
assistance okay next I'll talk about
disaster health information and the
scope of the information that we include
so the pyramid which you may have seen
if you've attended any of our webinars
previously shows at the top the
peer-reviewed scholarly literature which
is journal articles and books and
these things if you're familiar with
them they take a lot longer to publish
and a lot of disaster health information
does not get included in these types of
literature but the larger the much
larger base of the pyramid is what we
call grey literature which includes the
types of documents you see listed there
reports summaries surveillance data
training materials conference
proceedings these materials are not peer
reviewed but are no less authoritative
and they are available much more quickly
as well as being freely available you
don't have to be a subscriber to an
expensive database in order to access
them here's a definition of grey
literature that which is produced on all
levels of government academics business
and industry in print and electronic
formats but not controlled by commercial
publishers and for the purposes of
disaster that we deal only with the
electronic formats and our working
definition from day to day is everything
that's not in PubMed because PubMed
another positive NLM is going to have an
index of all the indexed peer-reviewed
articles that we talked about earlier
and so what we try to do and Emeric is
to supplement PubMed and not duplicate
the work and here are the kinds of
topics that we cover if you've been to
our website before our database these
are going to look familiar we cover of
course natural disasters like the
Hurricanes the season and the wildfires
as well as the sea burn incidents that
Stacy mentioned earlier chemical
biological radiological and nuclear and
explosive incidents we also focus on
some special topics like children and
disasters mass gatherings and we have
pregnant women and disasters ethics and
the very popular information guide of
ours is coping with disasters and lastly
we also deal with pandemic or epidemic
diseases outbreaks following disasters
as well as outbreaks that become their
own disasters such as the 2014 Ebola
outbreak ok for today since we're
interested in evidence I'm going to
focus a lot on our selection process in
great detail so our selection process
for the disaster Lit database is to
first of all select credible sources
then prioritize them follow them closely
and then make individual selections of
resources
so selecting resources much of this work
the Lord is the great majority of it was
done before I came to do Merrik
and we can see on our website there's a
list of the organizations that we use
for sources I'm going to hop over there
quickly now and see oops so I want to
show you our list
here's sources scan for disaster lit as
you can see there's hundreds these are
sources that we have deemed to be
credible authoritative and reliably
producing high quality information
related to disasters now following that
many very closely it would be difficult
so we've also prioritized them our
priority one sources are mainly groups
that you might have heard of already in
groups from the United Nations the World
Health Organization many US health
agencies and those the ones we follow
most closely in fact daily I'll talk
about in just a moment
but I should say although the majority
of sources have are already in place why
I joined emmerich we add sources
definitely monthly sometimes even weekly
depending on the kinds of resources that
we're finding so how do we follow our
Priority One sources on a daily basis I
have three screenshots here one of these
is um let's see hop over to the web
again I'm going to show you fili which
is a tool we use to follow RSS feeds and
you can see in our list here this is a
list of our priority one sources that
have recently published information in
their RSS feeds and over here if you're
not familiar with how these tools work
this is a list of the articles in the
feeds so I am in here daily reviewing
all these sources scanning them there's
a great deal I would say most of it we
do not add to disaster lit but every day
I'm finding things that we do end up
adding that are in scope in the similar
way we also monitor these same sources
on Twitter since that's a major way that
a lot of organizations release their
resources
so here's our list our Twitter list
always follow those and lastly we also
subscribe to newsletters and other kinds
of announcements by email from these
same groups so it's a little bit
duplicative but sometimes a group will
tweet something that they fail to put in
their RSS feed or it gets emitted from
their newsletters so we make sure we
catch everything that way so for the
resources themselves sis which is our
division here within the National
Library of Medicine has developed some
guidelines for selecting non NLM
resources they must be authoritative
incredible it must be current there's no
conflict of interest for advertisements
it must be freely available audience
appropriate and language appropriate so
language appropriate for us means it
must be available in English it may be
available in other languages as well but
it must be available in English and I
want to pause and emphasize current as
well we are as I said scanning daily for
new resources we do add some slightly
older materials but we also maintain
high awareness of current events so when
there are things like a very active
hurricane season or wildfires in the
western US we are scanning more closely
for resources that would help our users
respond to those disasters or how our
users help their communities respond to
those disasters and it informs our
selections on what I think I hid my last
slide so just to review really quickly
we we pick our sources based on their
credibility and authority so by the time
we pick individual resources from those
sources we could already count on them
being high quality information they have
to be in English than to be freely
available online and they have to be
current okay
now I'll talk about some of the features
of our disaster lit database as of
yesterday we had over 13,000 records
available our records have a few
different pieces to them including a URL
a source a brief annotation and
alternate links if there's other sort of
related links for the record
the second bullet here I want to
emphasize we link out to our resources
we do not host them in our database
we're not storing all these documents
and there's a few reasons for that I
mean one the main one being that it
improves the currency of our records if
we sort of scoop something up and state
it in our database we might not notice
if it gets updated but if we link out to
it
and it does get updated oftentimes that
link will break and we have a URL
checker to help us find those or else
the link itself will redirect to the
newer record so we want to make sure
that our users are always finding the
most current information and that's one
way that we do it
disaster lit this version of it has a
just a simple search know advanced
search but once you do have your search
results you can use some filters such as
source publication year format to narrow
down your results we have a handy list
of recent additions if you just want to
see the most recent documents that have
been added and there's a search guide
with a lot more detailed information and
some search tips ok I'm going to go over
to disaster lit itself and okay so
here's disaster lit and a little trick
that you can do they already did it I'm
not going to do it now because it's a
bit slow but if you come to disaster lit
and enter nothing in the search box and
click search it will pull up all records
so you can see that today there's
thirteen thousand five hundred and
twenty seven records and as I said there
are is a simple search but it does
support boolean searching so I'm going
to type hurricane and flood like so and
you can see that there it finds 84
records that have both hurricane and
flood so there's a few other features I
want to touch on they're sort of working
in the background here I mentioned the
boolean and you saw me use those
operators it does stemming as well which
means it's going to find different
variants
word forms and it uses some synonyms in
the background which is sort of custom
to disaster lit we use mesh terms so
what I enter the word hurricane is going
to find records not only with the word
hurricane in them but also with the word
cyclone typhoon and other synonyms that
you would find in the mesh vocabulary
and lastly you can see these filters
flip back here you can see flip filters
over here I've found 84 documents about
hurricanes and floods but maybe I want
to find only the training material so
under publication type I could check
that box and now I've restricted my
results to only that and I have nine
results okay there's my tip for finding
all records now and I had a search also
where I think I'm going to go back to my
all records and you can also look for
I'm going to look for some of our
partners in here so once again I'm going
to hit search on the blank search box
and it's going to pull up all the
records and then for humanitarian
evidence week it's a bit slow to do this
I should have done this earlier here we
go
for humanitarian evidence week I'm going
to look for here's all nap I'll check
them off it's going to restrict my
search to just records from all not so
you can also restrict to records from
particular sources this way by using the
filters and again for humanitarian
evidence week let's try search for
evidence you may have noticed that I
didn't mention evidence yet we don't
restrict ourselves to only
evidence-based resources but nonetheless
we do have a number of them in disaster
Lit so when I search for evidence I get
three hundred and forty-one returns some
very recent ones these are about the
opioid epidemic a lot of our recent
materials are about that also
anyway that could be a good way to find
evidence-based resources if that's what
you're looking for and lastly I know
that our audience is particularly
interested in humanitarian evidence
sorry I can spell it right you know look
just for the word humanitarian
and we even bought more records on that
711 including very recent things on
their engine crisis in Bangladesh using
social media safe spaces for women and
girls we have many many documents on
humanitarian issues okay if you're
particularly interested in evidence and
research and the point out one of our
filters down at the bottom here research
tools includes research tools and this
means quite simply correct me if I'm
wrong Stacy but that the the record is
talking about a document that includes
actual research tools such as survey
questions and that that correct right so
these are actually tools that have been
used and published about in most cases
so you can published about and they've
been used in a disaster specifically
okay so at this point I'll talk briefly
about the disaster research response
program which is a we're just a
trans-nih partnership with Dimmick and
nie HS which is also part of NIH and we
dr - as we call it has oh I don't know
why it's doing that
well I'll go back to my slide and show
you the slide I don't know why it looks
like that online there's a database of
tools and resources in dr - which is
literally a subset of disaster lit so if
you are in disaster lit searching and
you check the box that says includes
research tools those are the kinds of
resources that are going to be found in
dr - i did a search here earlier to
limit to specific disasters and the URL
is there you can try it yourself i don't
know why it's not working for me right
now okay i'm going to wrap up so that we
can get to our next speaker but let me
just mention a few things if you want to
follow us if you're not familiar with us
already there's a number of ways to do
that we have an RSS feed available on
the right side of our homepage you can
see new documents from disaster lit and
you click on more you'll get to access a
list of more recent documents that we've
added we have a listserv
which is a discussion group with about
1,400 people on it it's not too high
traffic but it is a multi partner
discussion so there will be other groups
besides us contributing to it if you
just want to hear updates for us you can
subscribe to our gov delivery list these
links are available on the left side of
our homepage under that stay connected
there's a discussion list and email
updates are the two choices you have
these webinars you'll get notified on
either of those lists when these
webinars are coming up or you can check
our homepage where we always announce
them or on Twitter very active on
Twitter and lastly I won't go into it
but if you want to embed our content on
your site that's also possible by the
HHS syndication storefront and I guess
these slides will be available later
with all the links that you would need
to access those and I've been showing
you our current site but I wanted to
give you a quick sneak peek of our new
site coming soon this is going to be
about our new homepage looks like it's
going to have the same great information
resources but organized hopefully better
so that you can find things more easily
and more quickly and it's going to
include some new disaster lit features
it looks similar but there's you may
notice there's an advanced search so
you'll be able to do like a multi field
advanced search which you can't do now
in the current version and some other
new features will be added so watch out
for that and I believe that's all I have
for now
should I take questions now and then are
there any questions I can answer now
where should we save it Dan it may take
a couple questions that takes us yeah we
still a couple minutes I'll take a
couple questions now yeah so we have one
user who is amazed at how much
information that we have it works with a
humanitarian organization and how can we
put our records in because it's very
important for people to see the reasons
you're helping internationally displaced
children okay well I would urge you to
email us if you let's see I have a slide
at the end here I was going to show this
later but you can see our email address
there if you have resources that you
believe should be in disaster lit you
can use that email address on the screen
that's NLM sis
di MRC atmail NLM NIH gov email us there
and let us know who you are and where we
can find your resources and we will
definitely check them out okay another
one was from Neil with the agreement for
disaster with national or global and I
have answered that our resources that
our resources although domestic and U is
focused because we are a federal
government agency are available to
anyone across the world and we do
include a lot of international
information and resources another
question was do we have examples of
information needs assessments of
humanitarian workforce so let's see
let's start shall we
information need assessment I'm just
going to type that in and see what I get
I feel like we entered some of these
recently but shows that back to me when
I searched on those terms I'm not being
very precise here but I searched on
those terms I'm getting a lot of
responses I wonder if I put information
needs in quotes here I would play around
with a search in this way this is
narrowed it down a lot information needs
assess in quotes that exact phrase and
assessment is bringing in 37 results so
I think these are going to be more about
information needs assessments that have
been performed already these it look
like they're mostly reports and things
that have been produced although here is
the CHS humanitarian standard manual for
self assessment I hope that's helpful
okay what are the most popular resources
for humanitarian workers that's hard to
say we don't know a lot about who our
audience is being the federal government
you may not realize this but we're not
allowed to track our audiences very
closely so we don't know in particular
what humanitarian workers are accessing
through our statistics anecdotally I
don't know if we have any particular
resources I just know that in general
that two of the most popular pages on
our website
have to do with coping and disasters
sort of psychosocial and behavioral
health issues as well as our disaster
apps page I yeah I would encourage you
to explore our website and look at those
within disaster lit I'm afraid I can't
say any more specifically we haven't
done any analyses and again we try not
to track who is searching for what we
don't we don't look at that in for
information and at most what we would do
is just see what across the board what
people have searched but then again we
don't know what what they would then
click on and what they would find most
most useful yeah and then the other
question is is there an a global
equivalent of dem record is asteroid
maybe someone else might be able to
answer that question we are not aware
when we have tried to look to see who is
doing it and we are somewhat global I
mean we do include information on
disasters and health from from around
the world and we do have a lot of
information from international
organizations as well so I don't want to
give the impression that we're solely
u.s. u.s. focus but I am not familiar if
there are others who were doing
something similar in developing cervical
awareness database in this area this was
something that was started and and we
had done our own needs assessment here
to see that that the concern was that a
lot of the literature was not getting
into the journal literature and
therefore not into PubMed and that so
generated a need for a database like
this that kind of ties in with one of
the earlier questions we had about how
much of our information or resources is
international versus domestic you have a
feel for the relative proportions so
that's a good question I don't know but
if you really want to know that send me
an email and I can I can figure that out
for you pretty quickly I think
but I don't know off the top of my head
please send us an email I think it also
quite depends what's going on so
certainly during something like Ebola
and Zika which were clearly
international
added lots and lots o during those time
frames it would probably be
predominantly international now that
we've had some domestic hurt you no
issues with hurricanes and wildfires
we'll be seeing more the domestic things
that are coming out
sometimes it just depends on what's
happening in the in the world alright we
shall now move on a to doctor packing
him Walsh and I will turn it over to you
it's fantastic and I'll just slide show
so like cookie everyone can hear me okay
thanks Robin and thanks everybody for
joining us for this webinar greater
seeing the work doing in to actually see
some searches in action fantastic um I'm
going to be talking about the project
that I run called health care
information for all we're a global
health network with more than 17,000
members in 177 countries and a website
is - org and I'm hoping that all of you
who were not already members will join
after this after this presentation and
this is a contribution to the
humanitarian evidence week where we are
working with national agreements and
that and and others and with evidence
aid to raise awareness of human terian
evidence and its importance now Stacey
gave me a nice introduction the
beginning thanks very much silence but
just to say that I have spent a long
time a checkered career you might say in
the starting that with as a doctor in
the National Health Service and then
medical officer for brief periods I
decided in Ecuador and Peru medical
publishing where I got interested in
information needs and then actually
working in the
meeting information needs some of my
friends say well at another time because
all of that lock took about 15 20 years
you could have saved a lot of time just
by training as a librarian right from
the starts and maybe maybe indeed they
are right I think I'm in a way I'm a
librarian at heart the outline for my
talk is I'm going to talk in the first
five parts about HIPAA generally and
then in the at the end I'll say a bit
about one of our projects which is
online services with a special emphasis
on disasters and humanitarian response
so starting with why HIPAA is needed
it's basically because people are dying
for lack knowledge often very basic
knowledge to literally thousands of
children and adults dying needlessly
every day because they don't receive
life-saving interventions and the
important thing is that these
interventions are actually often locally
available but they are simply not
provided due to indecision delays
misdiagnosis and incorrect treatment an
example that I like childhood diarrhea
now this simple disease causes more than
2,000 deaths in children every day every
day
and that's more than AIDS malaria and
measles combined and many of these
deaths in fact mostly due to lack of
basic health care knowledge among
parents and/or health workers now we all
know that a child with diarrhea
needs more drink needs rehydration
solution which is basically just water
with the right amount of sugar and salt
added to prevent death
but research shows and the references
are on our website that in India for
what intend parents actually gave their
child less to drink if they develop
diarrhea which is actually tragically
increasing their risk of their nurses
appalling and there are problems also
with regards to treatment by health
workers again in India one inch records
will give a child bateria antibiotics
instead of rehydration solution I move
but this this issue is not confined to
diarrhea nor indeed you that confined to
child health it's across the whole area
of health and so it's it concerns all of
us and especially us as librarians and
information professionals I did a review
with a colleague on the information
needs of health care workers and develop
in 2009 and the studies we found reveal
a gross lack of knowledge about the
basics on how to diagnose and manage
common diseases going right across the
health workforce and often associated
with suboptimal ineffective and
dangerous health care practices now this
is not something that is the fault of
the health workers most of them it is
related to a lack of app to health care
information and indeed failure to meet
other needs of health workers with
regards to for example medicines and
equipment in 2004 I published I
co-authored an article in The Lancet
with Fiona Godley who is now the
editor-in-chief of that BMJ chief health
information for all by 2015 and in this
article we
[Music]
said that we portrayed the issue as
being one of a failure of the global
healthcare information system this
global healthcare information system
persists warf health research producing
the publishing of health research
systematic reviews and guidelines
producing reference and learn and making
information available by definition this
system is not working because it is the
rule well being the exception that
people do not have access to the
information they need in low and middle
income countries when they need it so
our goal is a world where every person
will have access to the health care
information they need to protect health
and the health of others and when we
launched in Mombasa in Kenya in 2006 the
World Health Organization and gave us a
letter of support which said that Hitler
is an ambitious goal but it can be
achieved if all stakeholders work
together eat what we are trying to do we
are trying to bring together all the
stakeholders researchers librarians
publisher policymakers health
professionals and others in promoting
communication around information needs
and how to meet those needs we do that
through a number of online if a forums
we
extract the key points from those
discussions and place them into a heifer
voices database and use that information
for advocacy to promote increased
awareness of health information as a
global issue and also to promote
increased investments political and
financial in health information
activities we now have five forums in
three languages English French and
Portuguese and the main forum on the
left is HIPAA and then we have a child
health forum Portuguese French
understand a single country focused
forum HIPAA Zambia altogether we have
17,500 members and our main funder is
the BMA a strategic partner is the World
Health Organization this is a graph that
shows the growth of thoth Forum
membership since we launched showing
that we are approaching 18,000 and this
is the interface for our HIPAA voices
database where you can search on
different users of healthcare
information geography and so on an
example of our advocacy is that we
worked with the New York
to examine the role of governments in
international human rights law concluded
that governments have a legal obligation
under international human rights law to
ensure that citizens and health workers
have access to the information they need
to protect their own health and the
health of others so the website and I do
hope that you will join us by going to
this website after the webinar and sign
up of course it's free this is the
website here and just click on join or
go direct to the join page and a very
simple form to fill in and then you'll
will become a member and your journey of
discovery will be about to begin
if you're already a member then there
are lots of ways you can get more
involved for example you can become a
country rep and we have some 160 country
representatives around the world who
help to promote and encourage people in
their countries of Gioia you can also
invite your CEO or senior manager to put
in an application to become a hitter
supporting organization and we have more
than 300 supporting organizations now
around the world which are helping
development organizations that share our
concern about access to health
information and about 40 of those
organizations also provide a financial
education often it's only a small amount
no obligation if you choose to become a
sport organization to make a financial
contribution
way that you can get more involved with
HIPAA is by joining up with one of the
HIPAA projects and we now got 12 of
these projects active at the moment and
each project brings together volunteer
pithla members who have an interest in
the area concerns and we need a wider
hitter community in structured
discussions around the various topic
areas so I know like to focus
particularly on our library and
information services project which
starts at the beginning this year which
is particularly relevant to humanitarian
evidence week and webinar so our purpose
is to support communication
understanding and advocacy on the goal
of librarian illness in global health
and our current focus is on disasters
disease outbreaks and humanitarian
action the members of our group includes
representatives from the National Lab
emits alerts and Janet I see evidence
aid a healer Anna and the World Health
Organization and we are supported by
public health England our activities
include an evidence briefing a grey
literature search romantic discussions
on the forums and the support for
parents from Nigeria and sweet
now here are some personal reflections
on what discussion so far we are can't
be actually in art in the middle of our
second thematic discussion each one dots
four to six weeks we've had we had one
couple months ago and we are in the
middle of a second discussion now which
is on the theme of informed the
humanitarian action and what I'm picking
up from these discussions so far is that
it seems to me that humanitarians rely
largely on empirical knowledge ie in
fact lesson X alone such as is found
sphere and baggage and many of you may
be familiar with together with local
needs assessments and local permission
there's no availability of awareness of
information sources especially in the
only threat to me I think I'd get the
feeling that the disaster health
information sector isn't working as well
as it should be and that there is a
limited but important role for evidence
in court she MANET Arron Asham
and when we use this term we refer to
action that is informed by queue and
systematic review and this is analogous
to the term evidence-based medicine
there has indeed been an interesting
blog on the end of the tape website
published today which challenges whether
evidence informed humanitarian action is
actually useful or not and this is the
kind of thing that were discussing at
the moment and of course Library and
Information professionals have a Bible
Bowl
my thanks to all the people on the HIPAA
primary and Information Services project
working group who were listed here and
lastly I would just like to acknowledge
and thank all of the 40 organizations
that are supporting us in 2017 as I
mentioned many of these organizations
are I'll be able to provide a small
amount like sixty sixty or seventy
dollars speech but the total all outside
and overall Hitler is worming on an
annual budget of $45,000 a year
approximately was to increase that next
year so that we can engage more staff so
thank you very much for this as I say
again please do join PIPA or email me on
Neil at except
Thank You Neil that was great as a great
introduction to HIPAA for those who are
not yet familiar with it oh pardon me
let me show my screen
thank you so much I think we have a few
questions actually yes we the first
question is what qualifies as
information how do you assess the
quality of information that HIPAA seeks
to share and spread we if it does not
itself assess and formally assess and or
even distribute information we are if it
easier to think of us as a kind of
online conference where providers and
users of information come together to
discuss issues around how to improve the
availability of information for
different energies of grids contexts
so for example and we have a few hundred
members who are staff the World Health
Organization 2500 organizations
represented across the network so
primarily we are like a virtual cop
discussing the issues rather than
primarily a means of information
dissemination I think that there is no
such thing as a it would not be possible
for any organization to set itself up as
a be-all and end-all for information
dissemination the nature of information
meet is such that there there is
required a whole range of different
types of information formats in
different languages and at different
technical levels for each level having
said all this there are on HIPAA many
messages where people are making other
people aware of new and guidelines as
they are released so there is an element
of awareness of information and thereby
one of the benefits though not the
primary benefit of being a member of
HIPAA is that you will keep alert us to
some of the new literature but it didn't
actually set up to be a new service
okay thank you the other question we
have is based on the information given
how would this affect the internally
displaced children especially when
organizations help by giving relief
materials instead of the necessary help
that they need
I'm not quite sure where this come where
this comes in we don't any direct that
something to do it the question was
around internally displaced children now
internally displaced children is not the
primary focus of HIPAA however we do as
I mentioned to have a child health forum
called chipper which is concerned both
with the information needs of health
workers and families and children to
protect their own and help others and is
also concerned with health rights of
children so there is some discussion on
the chip forum around the information
needs of internally displaced children
and in fact there has been a couple of
conferences organized by shippers
administrating organizations we we look
in collaboration with the International
Cloud Health Group at the Royal College
at PDF in child health and the
International or social pediatrics and
child health and both of those
organizations have helped conferences
which have linked into HIPAA with some
discussions around issues to do with
refugees and this in the last few months
because sure you're all aware refugee
issue in Europe particularly for people
migrating home and the Middle East
and into Europe is a massive problem at
melons
great thank you I think that's it for
questions right now okay Thank You Neil
thanks for taking time to answer those
questions and thank you all so I don't
know that everybody realizes that this
event was especially coordinated for
humanitarian evidence week this week so
welcome to those of you who are new and
came through him in humanitarian
evidence week to hear what we had to say
there's been a lot of interesting
discussions and blogs online this week
around humanitarian evidence this
webinar will be has been recorded and
will be available online in a week or
two so check back with us in the
meantime you can reach us on the website
URL and our email are shown there on
this screen and if you want more
information from us and more information
like this about disasters I might point
you towards our training courses I think
Jen is going to put the URL for our main
training page in the chat box right now
and the link on the slide is for a brand
new course well it's a brendlin brand
newly reformatted course packing your
digital go bag it's about disaster
health information on your mobile device
specific apps that disaster responders
might want to consider loading on their
mobile devices to use and then Jen will
put the link to the training page which
has our other courses listed as well I
think that's it okay thank you everyone
for participating thank you thank you